we could be getting closer to a
coronavirus vaccine with promising
results from pfizer and others
for more on the timeline we're joined by
monsev slowly he leads u.s vaccine
development
for operation worth warp speed mr slawy
good morning thanks so much for being
with us
we could be just weeks away from a
vaccine
the first batch being distributed
according to secretary alex azar
who gets the first doses and
and how exactly will it be distributed
so yes we should be i hope
close to an approval first of the pfizer
vaccine
that has shown 95 efficacy will be
reviewed by the fda on december 10th and
maybe on the 11th or the 12th approved
within 24 hours from approval we plan to
distribute the vaccine in the case of
the pfizer vaccine pfizer themself
we'll be shipping the vaccine doses to
the
exact location that each state
will have uh identified as
the areas where they want the vaccine
doses the doses will be proportionately
to the population distributed for each
state
now who will get the vaccine is a very
important question that the cdc
and its advisory committee for the
immunization practices the acip
are reviewing as we speak and will
continue reviewing
until december 10th you know
the the uh also the american academy of
medicine has
recommended that high-risk people
elderly healthcare workers first-line
workers
should be part of the first race of
vaccines
yeah and how long do you think it likely
is before everyone will be able to get
it
within the first wave we think there is
about 110 million people
those should be covered based on our
plans
between the month of december and the
month of february
now the u.s population as a whole should
be covered in terms of vaccine doses
available
somewhere between the month of may and
the month of december so
on an ongoing basis month and month
we'll have more and more doses
to immunize to potentially immunize the
full population which we hope
will accept to be vaccinated mr
president-elect biden says he may alter
operation warp speeds vaccine
distribution plans has
has operations have the people with
operation warp speed
been in touch with the incoming
administration has there been contact
we have not yet been in contact we
understand that as of yesterday
the contacts will will start secretary
azar has said that we are
ready to discuss and of course share all
information that we have and
we will be happy to do it we think that
the plans we have
are very clear and and and very
thoroughly thought through
but of course we'll welcome every input
all right monster slowly with operation
warp speed thank you so much for being
with us this morning